no reject nation Greg Alba here with the
lovely and talented Kelly Russo Kelly
are you happy to be back so happy so
happy literally this is the next day
we're filming together
don't shoot things bad she wore the same
outfit I wore the same shirt might as
well just film yeah back-to-back anyway
Kelly have you seen true detective I saw
the first season I saw the first season
have you seen the second season I did
but I don't like to declare that I did
well I did not see the second season I
only saw the first season after a long
time we're finally getting the season 3
trailer here before we do that I want to
give a patron of the day shout out to a
man named commander dodge this guy is a
very handsome dude who is slaying it
with the ladies
you saw his profile pic man just tell
him how good-looking he is stud he's a
stud done when I was looking at his
photo to try to remember some stuff
about him so I could properly shine out
all Kelly was doing was going oh my god
Wow I have never been so turned on in my
life those are my words not hers
actually yeah you're a very beautiful
man sir aren't you happy you're part of
the patreon page sorry to use you like
sorry I'm just admiring another human
beings aesthetic so Josh nice looking
judge I didn't know if I was going
against all the meat to stuff I know I'm
having you talking about his looks oh
that's fun that's it's a different
situation that way before you get mad at
me I mean that decision she made she's
the human bean quality homeless body
odor that's what we call improv
before you ever knew me I wasn't scared
much I wasn't a fear for me I know it's
great actors things I've seen things
unknown into anything but cause home
my whole brains boat whistles whoa
well looks like really good
[Music]
there's no certainty
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
good oh dude they got the right actor
for this they got the right actor for
this not wait I didn't see season two a
true detective but one thing I really
did love about season one was the time
span it actually covered and it's
definitely doing that here you got him
it when he's a young cop with his family
and then you got him as an old cop I
don't know there's similar in season one
and season two in terms of my
comparisons for season one it seems like
it's harkening back to something of that
kind of aesthetic especially since a lot
of people didn't like season two for
this cop who's a family man I'm a family
guy who's haunted by this case over over
the course of several decades it seems
like what I like too is season one and
two seem to be about partnerships and a
nun sambal and I'm sure this will have
an awesome ensemble but this looks like
it's really just about Moe Herschel
elite you know a lone wolf captive
performance it looks just compelling
he looks phenomenal this one is also
going back to like southern territory so
much well yeah it makes for much more
like gritty vibe yeah cuz you're
southern freaks out there man bunch of
southern freaks we love everyone you're
all murderers and curves and just bunch
of creeps that is not true I'm quoting
you you said oh the rural South is small
town it's so private in LA and in
Southern California it's just it's less
intimate so it's not as scary and plus
they got like alligators yeah we got
traffic traffic that's the scariest
thing scariest thing in here is am I
gonna make it at work on time there's
something that's kind of like dirty
especially with the time period that are
taking place yeah I've never been south
so I actually have no idea if you guys
are all cool you've never been to the
south and now fine have you yeah is it
like this yeah I mean there's so many
and I don't know if I make it too big of
an assumption here but based off like I
hear it takes place in the Ozarks it's
the middle of the country and it's you
know very beautiful aesthetically yeah
like the first couple seasons was a very
white ensemble and it's kind of cool
that for the third season they're
getting an actor with it's such a high
reputation like mr. ollie I just saw the
movie black clansmen which I know it
takes place in a different area
but I love seeing a movie about a black
cop in an area that probably has a high
level of racism and I imagine that this
season will probably explore some of
that territory as well I know it's a hot
topic right now if you guys have been a
hot topic store it's a good store by the
way but and stuff now it's like for
everybody you know I like exploring
territory like that I think will be very
interesting and it also seems like with
the territory they have here that you
could probably even cross this over with
Matthew McConaughey or Woody Harrelson's
character from the first season as well
which I think would be awesome if you
actually really did tie it in like that
they have to be so good and I think
that's what the fans are waiting for to
of owning it
one and we're needing it I think what's
smart about this trailer from from what
we're getting here is that it feels
familiar more to the season one
territory but it also still looks like
it's exploring different aspects as well
which i think is the best direction you
can go because season one you ever won
season one came out yeah talk of town
hey you see true detective kid and then
season 2 came out everyone's like a
screw the show I hate this show now you
got a harken back to the first one so
fans for people who were so let down by
the second one will be interested again
here and I feel like they're definitely
doing that keep it in a similar you seem
geologic reader time-travel I mean
that's so hard to do and you have to
have a big budget do it any period piece
it's gonna be the first true detective
worry time travel you said the time
travel time trouble is us as you know
audience we times the time lapses in
every time lapse
we don't have Jones travel no it's this
is the first sci-fi version of true
detective everybody yeah
yeah that'd be cool don't steal my guys
it's not dr. strange I know but hey
whooping out that and that piece of info
right there you excited for true
detective season three I know Kelly is
I'm excited for my Harshal all these
awesome hairdo in his chair if I could
if I could do that I would not be
accepted guys you can subscribe to the
reject nation click that notification
bell Kelly Russo is on Instagram and
Twitter where she poses and nun outfits
it's very religiously appropriate yeah
she has a wide range of talent and
what's the name I just saw the trailer
for and the short film for this little
flick she did man-eaters you catch it on
YouTube girls a badass man she was
talking about the gun training she does
the martial arts training you should be
in something like true detective I would
love to give my agent a call well if
there's something HBO is constantly
watching its reaction videos plugging
yourself on the right video right now
never know man they'll like our reaction
to they're like we're hiring her keep
him off camera no look at this look at
this place he's a star cameras cutting
now